i had a basic decision to make
i either withdraw
america from a 20-year war
that depending whose analysis you accept
cost us 150 million dollars a day for 20
years or 300 million dollars a day for
20 years
who and i you know i carry this card to
me every day
and who in fact
where we lost
2448 americans dead
and 20
722 wounded
either increase the number of forces we
keep we keep there and keep that going
or i end the war
and i decided to end the war as i said
the other day
you know the only reason we're in
afghanistan is this is the place from
which bin laden attacked the united
states of america
had this been in another middle eastern
country where he could have easily have
moved from we would have never gone to
afghanistan so the question is
when is the right time to leave where
our national interest where do they lie
and the idea that we are in a situation
where we can
not recognize that terrorism has
metastasized around the world
and the need for us to focus on other
parts of the world to create an even
greater danger of an al-qaeda-like
operation beginning can't be ignored
and we are as you well know because you
follow this we are a number of places
where we're doing that without permanent
basing american forces there
so i i think when this is over the
american people have a clear
understanding of what i did why we did
it and but look
that's the job my job is to make
judgments my job is to make judgments no
one else can or will make i made them
i'm convinced i'm absolutely correct in
not deciding to send more young women
and men to war
for a war that in fact is no longer worn
on